[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
tell me if you lived in the wizarding
world what type of job would you want
some of you might have thought about
this question a time or two already
perhaps you want to be an aura at the
ministry of magic or a professor at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
you might think those are great choices
but they're actually a bit limited
there are hundreds of jobs to choose
from in the wizarding world and today
we're going to take a look at a handful
of some of the most interesting ones
from troll trainer to magical creature
breeder and more
activist there were no shortages of
issues in the world of harry potter
since the very first wizard appears in
historical records so have social and
political obstacles during the medieval
era wizards and witches found themselves
at odds with the muggles who lived among
them these conflicts were among the most
bloody and traumatic in all of wizarding
history throughout that time some
members of the magical community made it
their job to meet with muggle leaders
and convince them to enact change in
their kingdoms
at the very same time goblins regularly
rebelled against the wizards in the
magical world
just like the mughals mistreated wizards
and witches the wizards and witches in
turn mistreated goblins by the 18th
century some of these goblins even
became famous enough to earn recognition
as influential activists like ugg the
unclean
alchemist you can think of alchemy like
an ancient version of chemistry by harry
potter's time wizards didn't really have
much use for it in fact it was so
unpopular that it was rarely even taught
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
alchemy itself was pretty simple as a
field of magic it was mostly concerned
with three specific goals
changing tin steel or iron into gold
making a cure all medicine that would
make its user immortal and distilling an
acid that was strong enough to dissolve
anything
if you remember harry potter's first
year at hogwarts there was a french
alchemist who actually discovered a way
to live forever nicola flamel although
there wasn't much need for alchemy but
the rise of the modern ministry of magic
an individual wizard could try to strike
gold by choosing this career
apparition examiner apparition wasn't
easy of all the magical skills that
young wizards and witches could be
trained in this ability to teleport from
one location to another was among the
most advanced and it was extremely
dangerous too
it wasn't uncommon for wizards and
witches to be tested on their ability by
an apparition examiner especially in the
united states as their job name implies
an apparition examiner judged an
individual's ability to safely use the
technique without causing harm to
themselves or others
bartender there were plenty of unique
magical jobs in the world of harry
potter but there were plenty of ordinary
ones as well if you grew up with a
magical ability you wouldn't be limited
to a career the ministry of magic or the
magical congress of the united states of
america
you could take an ordinary job as well
one of the most interesting professions
was a simple bartender whether at the
three broomsticks in the hogs head in or
any other pub a bartender had the task
of filling drink orders and running the
business behind a bar with innumerable
magical cocktails and drinks the job was
actually one of the more interesting
ones in the wizarding world
magical creatures breeder breeding
magical creatures was a particularly
sought after skill while some muggles
like dudley's aunt margery enjoyed
breeding bulldogs wizards and witches
could breed far more exotic creatures
although the career drew the attention
of the ministry of magic from time to
time who was concerned with the
mistreatment and abuse of magical
creatures breeders were by and large
free to spend their days with the
animals they loved lord stoddard withers
was one of the most famous wizard
breeders of his day he bred winged
horses and even used them to create a
new sport flying polo
others bred more domestic creatures the
nasal a cat-like animal with a xxx
classification from the ministry was
often bred in order to safeguard its
owner's home and possessions arabella
fig was a reputable nasal breeder in
britain during harry potter's time at
hogwarts and earned enough money to live
a comfortable life
curse breaker
curse breaking was a tough business
that's for sure just like a bomb squad
defuses the bomb a curse breaker defused
curses
you might remember that ron weasley's
older brother bill worked as a curse
breaker after graduating from hogwarts
in 1989
and it might not seem like it but curse
breaking was actually one of the most
lucrative careers you could have in the
wizarding world
gringotts wizarding bank often hired
curse breakers to go on international
expeditions
in search of ancient treasure that they
could add to their vaults beneath diagon
alley when a treasure was discovered a
curse breaker was tasked with
investigating what type of horrible
illness or monster protected it
once while looking for treasure in egypt
bill even had to fight against a mummy
as part of his job
dragonologist dragons are among the most
fascinating magical creatures in the
wizarding world for that reason many
young matches zoologists are drawn to
the field of dragonology where they
studied the biology society and history
of the winged creatures
by harry potter's time most dragons had
been moved to magical reserves
due to the encroachment of muggles in
their natural habitat
while studying dragons in these smaller
territories wasn't as wondrous as
studying them in the raw wilderness
dragonologists didn't seem to mind so
much
compared to other more lucrative careers
a life spent as a dragonologist wouldn't
make you particularly rich
but those drawn to the job were never
chasing money anyway
they become dragonologists because of
their love for chinese fireballs
hybridian blacks and the rest of their
scaled cousins
healer compared to muggles wizards and
witches had far better healthcare the
contrast was starker in the ancient
world as well
before the rise of modern medicines
entire muggle towns and counties could
be wiped out by a particularly nasty
strain of the flu or a bacteria that
infested the local drinking water
while these types of ailments presented
the same problems to the wizarding world
magical cures ensured those illnesses
were far less fatal for wizards and
witches
and as the centuries passed and the
modern muggle world developed its own
advanced magical treatments the magical
healers remained superior
the process for becoming a magical
healer was just as rigorous as becoming
a medical doctor if you ever want to
hold one of these rare positions at st
muggles hospital for magical melodies
and injuries then you have to be at the
top of your class
and receive top marks on your newts when
you compare a healer's job to a muggle
doctor you'll find a few interesting
differences
since magical charms and curses were so
creative a healer's magic had to be as
well
when a patient rolled into the hospital
with a boneless limb or a cursed hand
healers had to use all of their know-how
to figure out what spells and potions to
employ
duelist in the second wizarding wars
it's hard to imagine dueling as anything
other than a way to win battles with
lord voldemort and his death eaters
standing against dumbledore in the
ministry of magic harry potter and his
peers study dueling
in order to prepare themselves for the
inevitable and tragic battles to come
but outside of warfare dueling had
another role in the wizarding world
just like quidditch dueling was a sport
and a natural outlet for young wizards
aggression and physical energy although
careers as a dualist were not very
lucrative with only the top combatants
earning a decent living many young
students often dreamed of becoming one
troll trainer when it comes to large
powerful creatures there are few
stronger than trolls and that makes them
the perfect security guards
although they're not very smart some
species of trolls could be trained and
assigned to protect wizards and witches
in the wizarding world
the process of training these trolls was
given to a troll trainer and it was a
fairly decent job for someone with a
knack for it
as you might expect training trolls
isn't without its fair share of hurdles
the gigantic creatures were clumsy at
best and deliberately murderous at worst
it wouldn't be uncommon for a trainer to
fly halfway across a room after
receiving a backhand from their troll
but the risk of bodily harm wasn't
enough to stop trainers from
participating in the profitable business
well there you have it 10 bizarre but
lucrative careers in the wizarding world
what do you think of them has it steered
you away from a potential life as an
aura at the ministry or as a professor
at hogwarts let me know which job you'd
choose in the comments below and if
you'd like to learn more about the
hundreds of other jobs unique to the
wizarding world be sure to leave that in
your comments as well
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]